look at your history for a second and
leave this [ __ ] Guns and Roses
and uh the coolest band in the world
even the logos and everything else just
cool every kid wanted to tattoo it on
themselves
they need to hook up with this Scott
Weiland who I know
and here we go again you say I believe
that that wasn't even fun like at the
time when I saw you with him you were
like yeah man this is great because
you're trying to sell it right you know
that was you know all things considered
you know that was something that I think
we knew going into what we were getting
into that it was going to be disaster we
just wanted to play right and it was me
and Duff and Matt and just like we had
done this gig where uh it was a
fundraiser for a friend of ours that had
passed away and so uh the guys from
Buckcherry Steve Tyler Cypress Hill Duff
Matt myself all got together and played
that night and uh Duff called me up the
next morning goes you know that was a
that was a kick-ass gig we should do
something with it and it was very
inspiring and I was actually about to
put together a solo project at that time
sort of do what I'm doing now and I
started piecing it together then and so
I got sidetracked with Duff and we went
and you know started putting this thing
together and we were auditioning like
I'd say like or at least listening to
about 200 singers a week for about two
months it's like America's Got Talent
yeah oh man it was miserable what do you
do when you auditioned a singer they
come up in front of you they they play a
little bit with you yeah they sing and
then you have to turn to them and go
okay next yeah more or less it's a
little bit more personal than that you
know it's like it's just the guys in the
band in a funky rehearsal room right and
the guy comes in and you say hey and try
to make people feel as comfortable as
possible do you know right away if a
guy's working or not sometimes you can
tell right the second they walk in like
30 seconds in yeah even his attitude but
then you know yeah yeah and then and
then sometimes you know you go through a
few songs and you work at it trying to
see exactly what's missing or do you
call those guys afterwards and say look
you know hey we thank you for doing this
but something like that yeah it's weird
it's got to be a weird scene the process
is but anyway so then uh the idea of
Scott came up and I was the only guy in
the band that didn't know Scott I didn't
really know much about his history I'd
heard some crazy stories about STP but
uh right we wrote a couple good songs
and you know with all due credit to
Scott there was a period in there where
we all fell off the wagon how long did
you fall off the wagon for you know what
it was it was pretty much that uh from
it was a gradual thing it started with a
a beer no it started with a bottle of
Jack Daniels when we finished mixing or
mastering the first record and I was
over at Sterling sound and I saw a
bottle of Jack and I've been clean for
about two years and I saw this bottle of
Jack it just seemed like the perfect
reward so that was that controlled thing
did you say to yourself like hey slash I
could drink a bottle of Jack Daniels and
then never touch it again was it that
kind of I don't know I just think I just
figured you know I don't think I put a
lot of thought into it yeah but I'm sure
you discussed it with yourself the next
day no no no no no no I can control this
right yeah it looks like I was not I
wasn't I'd never been to rehab at that
point I haven't done any meetings I
didn't know anything about all that
stuff and so and I had a great time but
then when when any friction when a lot
of friction started yeah with uh velvet
then it became a just very chaotic how
much alcohol would you need to get drunk
like would you need I didn't even get
drunk anymore I don't know it was just
sort of like a maintaining yeah these
sort of have like that that like you'd
get up in the morning and have a drink
oh yeah drinking a cigarette sometimes
[ __ ] I have the cocktail left over from
the night before and just finished and
that was really normal I mean that is
crazy right do you see how crazy that is
now or do you still think it's normal it
does as you know I mean I look back on
and go that's that's I mean even Ronnie
Wood who I used to go crap heco did
we'll take somebody else to point it out
to you